Film Courage: Can we go back to your script
reading days?
First off, what qualifies someone as a script
reader?
How do they know you are ready to be doing
coverage?
Adam William Ward, Director/Co-Screenwriter/Actor
of WALLY GOT WASTED: It’s so funny…nothing,
nothing qualified me at all.
I got the job and they started shoving scripts
in my hand.
I had no qualifications for that whatsoever
and that’s the truth.
I got better as I went.
I’m sure my first synopsis was kind of like
‘what the heck is this?’
But I’m doing three a day so eventually
I am getting better and better and better.
And that’s the thing too nothing qualifies
you in this industry.
If you want to make films, if you want act
or whatever you want to do, there’s no qualifications.
It’s not like every other job.
But at the same time the problem is the whole
world…it is the same when it comes to experience.
It’s not the same as the qualification of
“I went to Harvard.
You are qualified to do this job.”
It’s “Oh…you’ve done 15 movies.
I’ve seen the qualifications in the way
that I put a camera on you and you’re not
going to get nervous.
You are going to deliver.”
And all that kind of stuff.
It’s very different in that way.
And really the people that I see succeed are
the people that never give up, who keep learning
and getting better and better and it’s very
rare to see that because certain people get
to certain age and they want to have babies
and do certain things and certain things are
pulling them in certain directions.
And it’s very hard to do the same thing
if you haven’t hit the idea of what you
imagined.
But a lot of people come here and say “I’ll
give it a year.”
But if you wanted to be the CEO of Apple would
you give it a year?
Because that’s what this is.
If you’re a lead in the TV show, that’s
what this is.
You are a CEO of that company now.
You’re the face of that TV show.
Everyone is putting millions of dollars behind
you so you better be good, really good.
And have worked your way up and be the CEO
of that company because that’s what you
are at that point.
And the same thing with the director in a
movie.
Because if they give you 20 or 30 million
dollars or a hundred million dollars to make
a movie I mean the money speaks for itself.
You are a CEO of that company, you are completely
in charge of making that a good movie or a
bad movie at that point.
It takes that time to get that good and people
to believe in you.
Film Courage: So you didn’t have the qualification
to have what you thought you would have had
to be a script reader or you were just surprised
that they entrusted you?
Adam: It was mind-blowing to me.
Because before that point me and my brother
were writing scripts back in Oregon when I
had no connections whatsoever and we would
meet a guy who could get it to somebody else.
I’m now on the other side of it all reading
the scripts.
And I realized that when I was writing them
they were handing them to the intern that
had absolutely no qualifications and might
just not like my script.
Mostly anyone reading a script has absolutely
no qualifications whatsoever.
They read it and if they like it because of
their opinion, it goes up the ladder to someone
else who has more experience and more experience
and then eventually someone who maybe can
really look at a script and dissect the whole
thing.
But you have to get through all these other
layers of people who really don’t know what
they are doing.
It better be so good that they read it and
be so intrigued by it but it could also be
you ran into the right people (three people)
that loved your script or loved your idea
or whatever.
So mostly everyone reading a script has no
qualifications in the beginning at a studio
so the bottom layer people have no qualifications.
Film Courage: Would you ever stop reading
a script or your job was to read it all the
way through?
Adam: You are doing three scripts a day so
if I read and it’s just horrible the first
twenty pages I’m going to try to sum up
the script the best way possible.
I’ll read the last 15 pages and most of
the people in the office will tell you that
like somebody in there was like you should
ready the first ten and the last ten, decide
if you like it and then you might read it.
Otherwise that’s all that matters.
If it’s not good there get rid of it.
I ended up doing that sometimes and I felt
bad for people.
If it would bad it was bad.
That’s the thing like when you have a stack
next to you that is 20 scripts, not everyone
is going to get an opportunity.
So with the first 20 pages there’s no bad…the
whole thing has to be amazing.
If the first 20 pages are bad then your script
is done.
It’s not going to get to the next level.
And actually once I made a film distribution
companies tell me that first 10 minutes of
your movie better be amazing because people
will turn it off on these streaming platforms
.
So you better put a lot of your budget in
that first ten minutes, have a chase scene,
have other scenes, whatever captures them,
high drama, something to drag that audience
in because everyone’s attention span is
so short nowadays.
Film Courage: And then what was coverage like
even if it was just the first ten and the
last ten, what are you filling up on a piece
of paper of coverage.
Adam: So I wouldn’t write on the script.
I would write a one-page synopsis and try
to basically make an outline of the script.
Really if you did your own coverage you’d
be saving people a lot of time to be honest
with you because Hollywood people want your
movie in one sentence and then if they are
intrigued by their one sentence then they
will want to read a paragraph.
So if you write one sentence that sums up
your movie, great.
Then write a paragraph that sums up your movie,
great.
Then have a one-page synopsis that sums up
your movie, better.
And if you handed that off to somebody they
would love you to death.
And you can master getting each one of those
great because the intern is going to write
your one-page synopsis when you could have
done it yourself in a way.
Or your one-liner or your one paragraph or
whatever.
So that’s kind of how it is.
Film Courage: And so you then you got HANGOVER,
it landed on your desk?
Adam: They already loved HANGOVER, I didn’t
green light HANGOVER.
They already had HANGOVER and liked it.
That was one of the two scripts they were
developing at the time.
It was that script and another called MANWHICH.
And they were like these are the two movies
that we’re going to make.
Check them out eventually.
But at the time all of the excitement was
over the MANWHICH movie not over the HANGOVER.
And that was the next movie they were going
to make not HANGOVER and I was constantly
like…
And maybe Todd always knew he was going to
do HANGOVER.
I don’t know I wasn’t really talking to
Todd that much.
He came into the office once in a blue moon.
Scott Butnik was his partner at the time so
I had a lot more interaction with him.
And for me when I read it I thought it was
very funny and it’s a page turner because
it’s a mystery they are trying to find their
friend.
It was all solid, it was good.
And someone else actually wrote the script
and Todd and his partner re-wrote it.
So they didn’t actually write the first
draft of it.
And they went on to do some other movies and
stuff.
Film Courage: Eventually you saw that you
could become that guy or that girl and you’d
be making a nice living but you would be doing
exactly what you want to do?
Did you have a plan to get out or was it one
day you just threw a bunch of papers up in
the air and walked out?
What happened?
Adam: No, I was only at each place for like
three months and both places it was kind of
a short term thing anyway so it wasn’t like
I had to go “Oh I’m leaving.”
The time is up that you were supposed to be
here anyway.
That was nice in a way.
I didn’t get promoted you know what I mean?
It’s very hard for people to turn down money
when you first get here so for a lot of these
people it was like Oh now I’ve got $50,000…now
I’ve got $100,000…now I’m making $300,000
a year.
I have a wife.
How am I supposed to leave this job?”
You know what I mean?
You are money dependent on this job.
And I’m lucky they didn’t offer me a position
because I might have tried to embrace it which
a lot of people do embrace their 9-to-5 job
and give up on their dreams.
And I’m lucky that I was raised by my father
and by my mom and my dad always instilled
in me you can do anything you want to do.
You just have to go for it and not take “no”
for an answer.
That’s kind of my mentality with life.
You’ve got to go do it.
Film Courage: Did you see that in him?
Adam: In my dad?
My dad actually was a musician back in the
day.
And he was almost the lead singer in Aerosmith
when Aerosmith was having drug problems and
stuff and there was a guy named Arthur Mann
basically that put a contract in front of
my dad and was like “I want you to perform
in every club, bar, stage from here to China.”
And my dad had…my mom was pregnant at the
time and he had a real job and he had to decide…he
gave it up and he became a family man really.
And the same contract Arthur Mann gave it
to Bon Jovi.
So Bon Jovi ended up becoming Bon Jovi and
my dad ended up being a dad and shortly afterward
my dad got in a bad car accident.
So he ended up being a stay-at-home-dad and
my mom worked and so my house was very reversed
in the 80’s where the mom stayed home.
Where with my dad he was a stay-at-home-dad
so it was very different in that way.
But it’s kind of crazy though because he
trained my sister how to sing and so my sister
is ZZ Ward (she’s a big time singer).
And so the next generation still made it as
a singer.
She signed with Hollywood Records (which is
Disney) and she’s working on her third album
now.
So he passed up his music dream but she accomplished
it so it’s kind of nice to see that in full
circle for him.